how was your trip Oh wonderful and did
your wife enjoy it very much oh that's
good excuse me now mr. Jensen and dr.
cuates will be right in okay hello mr.
Johnson how are you today why not are
you well get this up just a little bit
that's better that's good now let's
check your this again mr. Jensen the
mouth is the most easily examined of all
body openings yet there's a tendency for
dentists to focus on the tea and gingiva
and for physicians to look through them
all to observe the throat systematic
examination of the oral cavity is too
often neglected twice each year with
every regular patient the dentist has an
opportunity to search for early cancer
now close together now open wide please
hmm biopsy site seems to heal nicely
sellers encouraging dr. cold which are
just a quite popular loop dr. Coleman's
are your first rate specialist I'd
certainly follow his advice What did he
say about the pipe smoking it's ajust a
discontinued well this will aggravate
your problem and I know but it would be
hard to do
now close together many dentists perform
a check-up for oral cancer routinely on
all patients although relatively
uncommon representing only one cancer in
30 oral cancer so often as a killer that
a persistent search is required except
for the lip the five-year survival rate
is less than forty percent but when
treatment takes place before the cancer
has spread survival as several times as
high as when lymph nodes are involved
absence of spread depends on very early
detection in one study of tongue cancer
forty percent had metastasized within
three months after the first symptoms
were noticed after 12 months ninety
percent had metastasized
oral cancer is largely a disease of men
well number the women affected by about
three to one this may be due to men's
greater exposure to various etiologic
factors such as sunlight tobacco alcohol
all of these factors manifest their
cancers affect increasingly with
advancing age squamous cell carcinomas
sometimes called epidermoid carcinomas
account for about eight out of 10 oral
cancers together with cancers reported
merely as carcinoma they make up more
than ninety percent of the total non
ulcerated soft tissue cancers usually
arise from major or minor salivary
glands these comprise about seven
percent of all oral cancers sarcomas and
lymphomas while rare are particularly
noteworthy because they occur in younger
patients squamous cell carcinoma does
not appear to originate in a single cell
but in an area of epithelium which
undergoes cancerous change at many
points these pulsar then coalesce to
produce a single tumor local growth is
followed by invasion of underlying
tissue which often spreads much farther
than the clinical evidence would suggest
in the wake of invasion comes metastasis
initially to the lymph nodes of the neck
in one study some forty percent of oral
cancers already involved lymph nodes by
the time they were diagnosed neglect in
further growth means eventual death by
strangulation starvation or hemorrhage
cancer in different oral sites presents
different problems the lower lift is by
far the most frequent site however lip
cancer develops where it is likely to be
seen early and the five-year survival
rate is high at least seventy percent in
contrast cancers of the tongue and of
the floor of the mouth are seldom
detected in an early stage and they
cause more deaths than any other oral
cancers at present the five-year
survival rate for inter oral cancer is
only about thirty percent this carcinoma
with its abrupt border in duration
ulceration and a history of duration and
growth would hardly be missed by any
practitioner but this is not early
cancer improved survival will come only
when cancer is detected before these
classical signs appear before it looks
like cancer I'll take a Kleenex mrs.
needle before I examine your teeth mrs.
Nagel I'd like to ask you some questions
have you ever had bleeding gums now have
you ever had these sores ulcers or
swellings that haven't healed promptly
now taking a history of oral conditions
is the first step in a routine
examination equipment for examination a
mouth mirror gauze sponge good
illumination and a high degree of
concern about cancer it's systematic
examination sequence is essential the
dentist looks for any asymmetry or
swelling and for changes in skin color
or texture by watching for neck masses
salivary gland tumors thyroid
enlargement and skin cancer he may reap
a bonus in case finding he searches the
lips for an area of induration elevation
or other surface irregularity
removing dentures will reveal lesions
which may otherwise be obscured drying
the mucosa aids visualizing variations
in color and texture he palp it's the
buccal mucosa to note any lump fixation
or in duration the gingiva
the palate
the tongue grasping the tongue with a
sponge eads him in examining the obscure
posterior lateral borders of the tongue
and tonsil hiller's where the likelihood
of finding an early cancer is greatest
using a mouth mirror as tongue depressor
makes obscure areas more visible say ah
please ah this drops the tongue and
raises the soft palate and uvula
revealing the tonsils falsies and post
pharyngeal wall checking for swelling or
lumps he pal pates the salivary glands
palpation practice routinely extends the
dentist perceptive senses gives him
educated fingertips he palpate the neck
tube and the cervical lymph nodes which
drain the oral region sometimes an
enlarged lymph node may be the first
sign detected before the primary lesion
has become apparent when infection is
not the obvious cause enlarged lymph
nodes suggest cancer until proven
otherwise well let me examine your chief
people tend to be unaware of early oral
cancer because it is usually painless
and presents no handicap the dentist's
greatest opportunity for salvage lies
with his regular patients in finding the
early lesions that one might not suspect
of being cancer this velvety red area on
the tongue is cancer any change in color
or texture like this should arouse
suspicion this whitish area on the
palate lies adjacent to a carcinoma but
this equally suspicious milk white
raised lesion is not cancer biopsy is
essential to differentiate benign from
malignant any lesion which persists
should be biopsied this one proved
benign
early carcinoma of the lip may resemble
common lesions such as cigarette burn
senile alas ptosis or chronic cracking
and fishery the history of duration may
help to determine how it should be
regarded this one is cancer here one
cannot observe the highlights which are
visible on nearby tissues any ruffin or
a trophic mucosa with altered
translucency may be cancer this tiny
ulcer could easily be mistaken for
denture injury it proved to be a small
squamous cell carcinoma this lesion with
its papillary warty surface is brucas
carcinoma this lesion also is not all
serrated being small in size and located
posterior to the denture bearing area it
might easily have been overlooked
diffuse in its distribution this cancer
mimic infectious disease whether all
serrated or not any undiagnosed lesion
of more than 10 days duration should be
biopsied watchful waiting while treating
only the symptoms may prove fatal to the
patient in short anything unusual maybe
cancer any increase in size any color
difference any persistent ache or pain
any erosion any change the future of the
person who does have cancer lies largely
in the hands of the first practitioner
who has the opportunity to initiate
action because time is so critical often
meaning the difference between life and
death the dentist should refer the
patient to a specialist who is skilled
in the management of cancer to assure
the best possible treatment
mrs. health would you get dr. Walker on
the phone please Yes Doctor mrs. horn
you have a small spot on your palate
that needs special examination it may
require a small sample to be removed for
our microscopic study I'd like to have
you see a doctor Walker tomorrow could
you arrange that please I guess so but
does it have to be so so well usually
such conditions are minor but there is a
possibility that it could need quick
attention and we really need to find out
I have dr. O'Connor cancer oh thank you
mrs. off thank you hello dr. Walker this
is dr. Auster camp speaking I have a
patient here was a lesion of the power
I'd like you to check her name is mrs.
Willis horn did you possibly see her
tomorrow at two thirty why doesn't he
just take a biopsy specimen himself he's
qualified yes years but what about that
when might a dentist take the biopsy
himself and when mighty refer it well if
he feels that it is a cancer he should
send his patient right to the specialist
tool treating then the lesion won't get
any unnecessary handling fine any other
ideas well whenever the nature of the
lesion is uncertain it should be
biopsied patients often tend to
procrastinate so the biopsies best done
by the dentist while the patient is
still seated good and what does this
lead for exploitative cytology mr.
Richter I'd say even more than before
because of suspicion is upgraded so are
all the tests exfoliative cytology
should be done when clinical judgment
wouldn't indicate biopsy but this
surface scraping test can leave a
deep-seated cancer undetected especially
if it is covered with leukoplakia true
and cytology appears limited to finding
only one type of cancer epidermoid
carcinoma keep in mind that neither a
negative cytology nor even an egg
biopsy rules out cancer it simply means
that cancer cells were not seen in the
specimen submitted if the condition does
not behave as you believe it should it
should be checked again hello dr. Walker
did mrs. Horne see you for the biopsy
yes she did I just got the report it
shows verrucous carcinoma fortunately
this is very amenable to surgery we'll
plan her operation in the morning when
biopsy confirms the presence of cancer
how his treatment determined what are
the principles that govern therapy the
treatment for a cancer is determined by
its location its extent it's
pathological characteristics and by a
knowledge of its natural history or
behavior has experience shown that a
particular cancer is best treated by
radio therapy or surgery or by a
combination of methods if surgery is
selected the extent will be governed by
the need to remove involved tissues with
an adequate margin if the surgeon
doesn't remove it the cancer will
fortunately early oral cancer seldom
spreads beyond the lymph nodes of the
neck even when the cervical lymph nodes
are involved cure is often possible when
radiotherapy is selected it must be
equally radical and expert to eliminate
cancer without excessively damaging
normal tissues are the functions of
organs are the patient's appearance for
some conditions the coordinated use of
surgery and radiotherapy may be the most
beneficial this requires teamwork by the
pathologist the surgeon and the
radiologist the prosthodontist should
participate when the treatment will
result in an inter or oral defect and
there is no indication of spread the
treatment can be less radical
when more head and neck cancers are
detected early primary lesions can be
controlled with pure disabling
operations and with favorable prognosis
for more patients after cancer is
treated frequent follow-up examinations
are imperative even a small lesion may
metastasize but this bread may not be
detectable for some time moreover the
person who has had oral cancer may
develop additional primary tumors our
local recurrence or metastasis the
patient must be taught to participate in
his follow-up by reporting anything
unusual without delay and by keeping his
appointments for periodic reexamination
mrs. horns dentist was able to arrange
early treatment because mrs. horn
belongs to the forty percent of our
population that gets regular dental care
improve public education is one means by
which we may reach the other sixty
percent true the person who realizes
there is something wrong with his mouth
will very often go to a dentist but he
may take a dangerous amount of time
getting around to it in one study the
average patient with oral cancer put off
seeing anyone until eight months after
he noticed the lesion when the typical
patient has it checked it is no longer
early however the dentist can still play
a role in Salvage by seeing that his
patient receives immediate and proper
referral he can also prepare study
models before cancer treatment so that
when a prosthesis is made it will
closely restore the patient's normal
appearance what procedures are now in
store for the cancer patient whose
disease has spread beyond the primary
site many of these cases call for
immediate radical surgery and neck to
section
if the surgeon doesn't remove it the
cancer will end results of such
procedures are very gratifying but the
patient whose life is preserved may
wonder for a while if it's worth it
functional impairment and disfiguration
lead to depression and hopelessness the
prosthodontist who is called in
beforehand can often provide an
appliance within a week after surgery
this will lessen the contraction of soft
tissue and what it does for the
patient's ability to feed himself to
swallow him to speak will once again
give him hope uh-huh treatment today is
providing oral cancer patients with much
more than just greater life expectancy
what this prosthesis means to you it
means my very life doctor without these
I might as well be dead I couldn't nay I
can't live without them I can't eat
drinks I can't talk it's an important in
my life that's what it is
dentists can save thousands of patients
every year and thereby ensure for them a
meaningful extension of life
you
you